Welcome to my crib!
Do you want a tour?
This is my bedroom.
This is my living room.
This is my kitchen.
And this is my bathroom.
Because I...
am in this.
There’s a whole AirBnB category
just for shipping containers.
And behind that is a couple of things.
There's this fantasy that you buy
a shipping container for $4,000
bring it to a mountain, and you’re happy.
You’re happy now.
And the other is that if
you want affordable housing
containers homes are the answer according
to this, and this, and this, and this...
So is it true?
No.
About a week ago I drove through a
ton of fog Warrenton, North Carolina
to stay in a shipping container.
I brought some food props to make some elaborate
shipping container models out of graham crackers
which my editor was skeptical that I could pull off
but I told her that I used to
have a graham cracker addiction.
So...
full proof.
And then I got to my house.
No, the one behind that one.
After I bonded with other
guests, owner Michael pulled up
who built this development with a tiny house,
another shipping container, and my house.
It's your home for tonight.
Were you nervous cutting such a big hole?
I really believe in my team, you know, and they
will tell me if they believe they can't do it.
To really re-emphasize, this
is considered a real house.
Later on, propped up agains the house, I found
the cut out pieces of my actual container.
That is very cool.
You can actually see some of
the printing of the container.
That creativity is the promise
of shipping containers,
which I was gonna demo with my graham
crackers, and it started out great...
Look! I did it!
But...
No! No, no. No.
You were right.
Here are the supposed pros behind
the shipping container home.
It’s standardized.
This one’s 40 by 8. 320 square feet.
That means they’re stackable.
They can be modified with a
simple cut through the steel.
And you can just crane them... anywhere.
They’re also super strong because
these things are made to carry stuff
in big stacks across the ocean.
And best of all, you can get them super
cheap because containers are everywhere.
It's still raining a bit and I'm
totally hopped up on sugar now.
So I thought I'd give you some reflections
on my first night in the shipping container.
It's pretty interesting.
I definitely don't notice the size element.
I don't feel constrained by that at all.
And the way that Michael made the bathroom
large makes it pretty easy to get comfortable.
There's this lock on the garagedoor
that you kind of... click shut.
Makes it feel like a panic room.
Which I actually like.
Because it makes me feel like I'm important.
It's like a good hotel room with
a real creative touch to it.
I'm going to go to sleep now.
But something cool isn't necessarily practical.
Or easy.
Before I partied all night long
in Warrenton, North Carolina.
Just gonna eat this bad boy...
I talked to two people about
whether shipping containers
are practical affordable housing
or if they're kinda of overrated.
One is Belinda Carr, an architect
who has a Youtube channel
that racks up huge views forvideos
about stuff like insulation
and actually went viral with a video that
wasn’t super positive about shipping containers.
And I talked to Mark Hogan, an
architect who wrote an article
7 years ago about shipping containers
and is still part of the big debate.
There's no debate. I mean... they're garbage.
It was a very old argument
when I wrote the article and
someone keeps recycling it every six months.
It comes from me in architecture school.
Almost every year they were
pushing this idea of modularity...
the idea that a home, each part
of a home could be a different box
and you could just switch out the
box if you wanted to expand the home.
And and we were kind of brainwashed in that sense.
Everyone. I'm talking about
everyone in architecture school.
And then I got to the real world and I
started like diving into building science
how things are constructed, not just
how things look, but how they function.
Slowly, this argument about modular
shipping container construction fell apart.
It's an interesting look. And it appeals to people
because it seems logical.
As long as you don't think about
it for more than 5 minutes.
One of the first thing you see
with these houses is stacking.
The way containers work is
they have these four major
structural points in the ends of the container.
They're supposed to bear most of
the weight on those four footings.
So when you see them on a ship out in the
ocean, they're all stacked vertically.
Once you start offsetting
it or turning it at an angle
no other part of the container is truly structural
or can bear the weight of the container.
So you have the reinforce it.
The same goes for cool windows,
and doors, and garages.
When you cut a hole, you need to reinforce.
The container itself has made
it a very thin, flimsy metal.
But because of the geometry
and the corrugations...
it basically functions as a box
beam that that makes it stronger,
which is why you can lift it up with a crane
and put it on to a ship.
As soon as you start cutting holes in it, it no
longer functions structurally as a beam anymore.
If you are able to get labor for
all that to a remote location,
you’ll still need to build a
foundation for your container
to clear building codes and be stable.
That could be a slab, or piers,
and then it’s stuck there.
And you need utilities too.
So this is actually with a real
foundation, and it’s concrete piers.
And then we welded the shipping
container onto the piers itself
So this is actually considered
a house on a very small scale.
Modular design is great, but to make it livable,
you have to add expensive, and
pretty permanent, insulation.
So we took a shipping container,
we did spray in insulation...
and then we put the tin over that insulation.
And then it met the code requirements.
The thing that I responded to in the article
is the idea that it was a solution
to building low cost housing,
which is usually what it's presented as.
And it's clearly not that.
The overall project’s not
very expensive for a house,
but per square footage it adds up.
Okay, so shipping containers are
so bad, why are they still a trend?
I came to the conclusion that as affordable
modular housing they're wildly overrated.
But as cool, fun things to stay
in and to design... they work.
Also, I went on Getty images and, yea...
shipping container housing for
Ukrainian refugees is a thing.
It definitely makes sense for
temporary, really fast housing.
But as an environmental or
affordable housing solution?
The next morning, I had breakfast.
I slept well, I mean, I felt very safe
because I've literally seen all the entrances
and exits hanging against a wall.
It was, go to sleep and take a really nice shower.
They had a double shower and heated floor.
Let's get some jam on here.
I finished my graham cracker nachos and packed up.
Later, at home, I went on
Vox Media's music service
and searched for a song that was bittersweet.
I don't think I've ever met anyone
who built something
out of shipping containers who said
they would do it again.
The obsession I think is that people
think they've come up with a workaround.
And then they don't want to be proven wrong.
And so they just dig deeper
and deeper into this hole.
I think humans have this
obsession with modularity.
It's this vision people have in their head of
"oh, if I want to grow my home
or if I want a larger bathroom,
I can switch out this container
and bring in another container."
And the idea that if my home wants to grow,
I can add in two more containers
and it can grow that way.
How did you feel when you
first saw them on the site.
There was a sense of excitement,
but then I looked at my bank account
and was immediately disappointed.
Because I realized it was
really going to be a challenge.
You have to be a little naive and
arrogant to do something like this
because it is a lot more work and
money than you initially expect.
Warrenton, North Carolina is a tiny town but it’s
known for the revival Greek and
Roman architecture they built.
It's kind of artificial.
Car.
In the same way that shipping containers are
a form but they aren’t
necessarily practical to live in
all these columns don’t makeit easier
or more functional
but they did connect the people of
Warrenton to a cultural legacy that existed.
And that’s kinda what we do
with shipping containers too.
I mean, we live with stuff that is moved
around in these things, all the time.
So why not occasionally expose
them to our daily lives.
It might not be practical to live
in them, but it might be meaningful.
Even if it’s not as easy as it seems.